out to a beach
[Music]
this is a story about Saudi people not
Saudi politics very steamy here geez on
Saudi Arabia 5:30 in the morning and off
to some islands off the coast there
their beautiful islands Ferris on
islands with nice beaches
[Music]
here on fetes on island took a taxi in
to this town now I got to figure out how
to go see some things Salaam
okay
the students
just gave me - I don't know what you
call these rounds of red for free
didn't wanna charge me taxi shooting uh
okay I have my friend in we are trying
to negotiate a trip a lot of bargaining
[Music]
got the plan out to a beach and I heard
an ottoman building of some sort that's
how I made out of it huh Turkey yeah
yeah yeah
this is a very interesting part of the
world
so we're 50 kilometers from the saudi
coast across the Red Sea is I believe
you're at rheya
Djibouti not that far away a lot of
trade world powers have moved through
this region and there is no signage and
in English but from what I gather it's
an old Ottoman fort that is so little
holes I read it and I was told the
people of this island are very friendly
you know it islands say especially in
this part of the world there may be all
parts of the world take on very
different identities and so I'm sure a
lot of these people never even go to the
mainland so they're living in their own
world their own tribe I was told
yesterday by a guy that things are still
very tribal in the villages so there's
there's what would you call him a chief
soul Aman Sultan I don't know it's not
Sultan whatever you call him at whatever
the travel leaders name is Arabic a lot
of these smaller places still have that
this was part of the Ottoman Empire
right after World War one this all fell
and well the Saudi nation came to be a
warning do not break the rules in this
country I feel like it's a very safe
place to travel but there are very clear
lines and you don't want to cross him
it's basically common sense stuff the
one hard one is the one gray zone I'd
say is video and photos like you don't
want to directly shoot at a woman but
and then if it's a in a public setting
and you're not directly shooting at
someone I've been told it's fine but
I've heard different things from
different people and different things in
different regions doing my best here to
show the story and be respectful to the
locals here that don't want to be on
camera but I'm sure I've messed up a few
times beautiful though I don't know what
it is
wish I did we should you go in but it's
here feda sun island it's a mysterious
place well look at this that's cool
interesting lot of history here I'm sure
so this is one of the tricks to in this
part of the world is the numbers are
different
zero
[Music]
[Music]
mohamad just dropped me off at the beach
he said his friend is gonna pick me up
in two hours so here we go guys this is
beach culture Saudi Arabia style
actually better than I thought
nice fine sand clear waters not the
Saudi Arabia we usually think of right
beach culture
quite one you can see they just put this
here they'll probably go down the beach
and countries are either building their
infrastructure or they're decaying for
my impression so far in Saudi places
building whether that means things are
good here economically hard to tell us
with tourists it's properly it's
probably hot down here this is this is
this is real heat
this is serious heat this is heat that
just kicks your ass melts you in your
place
slows you down makes speech slower that
type of heat it's the real deal
I'm gonna go in that's what I'm gonna do
I got a swim most countries you get more
of an understanding with time the two
exceptions to this would be India and
Saudi Arabia in a different way so in in
Riyadh my second day I saw a woman there
with spite green hair no head cover at
all next to her was a woman fully
covered they are friends there's a lot
of opening happening right now in
certain ways but there's a lot of
there's a lot of mystery there's a lot
you just I just feel like I haven't
scratched into it yet I don't want to
say I'm frustrated that's part of what
travel is if you're interested if you're
curious you want to know more of what
the life is like in Saudi Arabia is not
an easy one to understand which well I
think piques everyone's interest right
why are people interested in Saudi
Arabia it's been somewhat secretive it's
been closed off tourists haven't been
allowed here until a month ago nobody
even here understands that tourists are
allowed everyone says who do you work
for it so no I don't work for any when I
traveled here on my own and they say
well why would you they just curious
they're like confused at that notion
yeah this country it flips everything
it's you know what do what do you think
when you think Saudi Arabia think
Wahhabi ISM strict religion oil desert
yeah all that's here but then this is
here I was told the party scene is huge
here underground this was in Riyadh I
was told I thought it would honestly be
a little more standoffish like people
would be more closed and with some
information yes like you cannot talk
about politics at least I haven't so far
and it's sort of rude to come in and hit
someone on politics in the beginning or
whatnot but in a few circumstances I
felt like it was the right time to dive
into that conversation and I got some
weird like it was like a riddle is like
we can't puzzle together the thoughts in
these conditions right now meaning like
we can't talk about this right now as
some it was something like that was
really strange so it was this guy very
up on things very well-traveled
very very open you know I was I was
dressed
traditionally he was dressed like like
an American kid and we could we could
connect on all levels but when the the
politics thing came out and that's
that's the no-go I'm not here to judge
any of this stuff I'm just giving you my
observations I do like that one thing
about Islam is salat the praying of five
times a day I'm not a religious person
but I really respect that and I like
that like from a tribal perspective it's
very human to gather multiple times a
day with the same people and that's
probably why mmm things feel somewhat
cohesive here I would say people seem to
have a lot of friends there are a lot of
family members I hope to come up with
more answers for you as the journey
moves on I hope to give you more clarity
but it's hasn't been the easiest one to
be honest
usually I can get a better pulse on a
place I'm still trying to figure this
one out because my head is completely on
it's on its head for lack of better
words but until then let's look at this
the guy mo who dropped me off he said
his friends coming to pick me up to
bring me to the ports but he's not here
so I'm gonna hang here this is this is
very valuable real estate in these parts
the shade seriously could definitely
cook eggs there if you wanted I actually
would like some eggs but I don't want to
cook them there yeah
[Music]
that's a little taste of Paris on island
it's a pretty big island actually so if
you're gonna come get it bring a car
definitely bring a car put a couple days
into it that was a little scratch little
teaser interesting place really
different than what I'm used to
now I'm gonna go pass out in the
air-conditioning